okay everyone more big Game of Thrones
news came out this week with reports
about a second game of Thrones prequel
series officially in the works now we
had already gotten reports not long ago
about won Game of Thrones prequel series
produced by George R Martin and writer
Jane Goldman that one will take place a
thousand years before the current events
it but in the Age of Heroes and I'll
explore more of the mystery the White
Walkers and the pilot of that first one
will begin shooting in October so it's
coming it's gone soon but the second
series is going under the working title
Empire of ashes and it will tell the
story of the doom of Valyria now in the
backstory the Song of Ice and Fire
series Valyria is like the ancient
empire that was mysteriously destroyed
and some natural disaster event that's
called the doom of Valyria some people
say it's a volcanic eruption or meteors
it's not really clear it's a mystery
it's kind of like Atlantis or Pompeii if
we didn't know what destroyed Pompeii
but there is a creepy poem about it
that's worth reading it's in the books
the hills that split asunder and the
black that ate the skies the flames that
shot so high and hot that even dragons
burned the city of a thousand years and
all that men had learned that doom
consumed them all alike and neither of
them turned in Game of Thrones we
actually briefly saw the ruins of
Valyria when Tyrion Lannister and surge
or Mormont voted through it remember
that was the time when Jorah got
infected with greyscale plaque psoriasis
now Empire of ashes will also tell the
story of the origins of House Targaryen
the it was a minor family of the
Dragonlords and old Valyria who rose to
prominence by fleeing to Westeros just
before the doom leading them with the
world's only living dragons the
description from this from this release
between the two of these which are you
guys more excited to binge and dig more
into and I need to be down for I mean
dragons are always gonna be fun but the
White Walkers are pretty more are gonna
be more interesting for me I'll say that
I'm bored with that but I think also
because in the books there's a lot about
that Age of Heroes and like there's so
many questions that are unanswered and
there's huge decisions that are having
to be made and then the Targaryen family
line like is definitely a really
complicated family drama series so in
terms of Game of Thrones like I'm more
excited about the other one and
cool thing for you Sam about the dragon
one is there's gonna be a lot of incest
on that one which I know is your
favorite part of the show I always love
it when you have like these genre these
genre properties that have like a deep
mythology that isn't really like there's
a lot of mystery to it and then they
love to just dive in like hey let's take
all the mystery away because that's
always what people want and it's not
anyway it takes some of the fun cuz it's
never as cool as you imagined I thought
as you're talking about that it'd be
really interesting if they treated these
spin-offs as almost like an anthology so
like season one is Age of Heroes season
two is the Targaryen family if there is
a season three like each season it's
another part of the of the mythology
it's a bit of Robert's rebellion woo
yeah it's kind of like you don't have to
because after the doom of Valyria
well my point there's not a story
existing there yeah so they're gonna
have to invent like one sentence about
each generation yeah and so then if you
if you did like an anthology thing it
gives you an opportunity to like hit the
highlights but not necessarily have to
build out something that's supposed to
be as rich and compete with the Game of
Thrones itself so the story is the key
can they tell a good story I think one
smart thing to do is don't tell the same
kind of story in both wonder-percent
because that's going to the better call
Saul example that's it's a very
different show and I also I think better
call Saul is a great example too because
it uses the clout that Breaking Bad got
it to do something they if you just
pitch that show cult it would have never
gotten made but with Breaking Bad behind
it they'd be like yeah and you want to
take like it's so procedural it takes so
much time with just little details like
one likes like trailing somebody using
like a baby monitor yeah and like it and
so these Game of Thrones spin-offs are
able to use like use the Game of Thrones
name to tell fantasy stories that no
they would never be allowed to do
otherwise interesting yeah yeah so
obviously I am the question for you guys
is gonna be which one do you guys are
you guys more excited about but I have a
bonus question on that do you think that
this idea about AT&T purchasing HBO the
the question was 18 she buying tea
buying HBO
well there is a new support at the new
Bosco on HBO like it's gonna be a hard
year because we've got to churn out like
three times the content because
miksa and it was like it was like I
don't know about you guys but like
reading that it was like really
depressing cuz it's like I like the way
HBO turns out college less is more like
it but it turns out less but it is it is
the best content out out there borrowing
an FX maybe you're an amine like yeah
well let us know what you think about
these upcoming HBO prequel series which
one are you more excited to see would
you like to see another one that's not
being a clue drying out there were four
in the works for a while and they've
narrowed it down to two but we'll see
what happens and as always subscribe to
new rock stars for all of our Game of
Thrones news and analysis